with the reveal of gear 5 we've learned
the shocking truth behind Luffy's devil
fruit because for years we've all
thought that he ate the rubber fruit but
in reality he ate the human human fruit
model NAA the fruit with the most
ridiculous and insane powers in the
world and throughout the story it
honestly kind of feels like destiny that
Luffy of all people actually got to eat
this fruit in fact it almost seems like
the fruit chose him and not the other
way around but what if the fruit had
been eaten by someone else What If
instead of Luffy it was eaten by a
different straw hat and we're not just
talking about the already pretty strong
members of the St crew like Zoro Sanji
eating the fruit but what if the
weakling Trio actually had eaten the NAA
fruit now for those of you who don't
know the weakling Trio consists of Usopp
Nami and Chopper and while these three
have their own strengths fighting is not
necessarily their favorite thing that
they do in fact more often than not
these three are actually quicker to run
away screaming then to actually face
down a powerful enemy but would that
actually change at all if they had one
of the strongest devil fruits in all of
One Piece well Usopp is probably the
likeliest of the weakling Trio to
actually come into contact with this
fruit in the first place that's because
after Shanks and his crew stole the
naika fruit from the world government
they had it to fusha Village in the East
blue however in this alternate timeline
we're just going to say that yaso the
great decided to actually go visit his
son you know instead of being like a
complete dead beat of a father and so
all it would have taken was the red
pirates making a just a quick pit stop
at Sarah Village and bada boom bada bing
we finally got one stretchy Usopp now
it's been kind of hinted at that the NAA
fruit actually has a will of its own
it's kind of managed to avoid being
captured by the world government for
over 800 years after all so it very much
seems like the fruits somehow ended up
choosing Luffy but let's just say that
Uso seeing his father filled him with
adventurous spirit and courage and
therefore deemed this future Brave
Warrior of the sea worthy of its own
powers now as we all know very well the
honomi model snika appears to be just a
regular rubber fruit before it's being
awakened so the first result of Uso
gaining this fruit is that he'd have a
rubbery body just like Luffy and one
benefit of this is that he's already
long nose could become even longer
however the real benefit here is of
course that this power would actually be
kind of perfect for Uso when you think
about it for one he wouldn't really need
his slingshot Kabuto anymore because if
usopp's entire body is elastic I mean he
would be the slingshot and a really
powerful one at that I mean for example
just imagine how sick it would be to see
USO in Rosa making his coolest shot in
the series so far sugar is about to take
out luff and law out of commission
completely and Usopp has to take her out
from miles away but this time instead of
firing a around that looks like his own
face Uso just yeets himself with perfect
observation hockey Precision but beyond
being able to fling projectiles and
himself super far though Uso's real
Advantage with this fruit might be the
durability that comes with being made
out of rubber after all only very few
characters can actually take a beating
like Luffy can with his fruit especially
from blunt objects like you know bullets
or fists or whatever however the only
character that seems to take even more
damage than Luffy throughout the story
and then inexplicitly recover is
actually Usopp so really say what you
want about the man he's not super strong
yet he's not always brave but most of
the time but usub can really take a hit
this is a guy whose whole skeleton has
been shattered on numerous occasions and
then just shakes it off to be walking
around the next chapter and just imagine
if someone like usub was actually made
out of rubber how perfect that would be
he would probably survive beatings from
kaido himself at this point like would
he ever be able to hit hard enough to
actually beat an opponent like a yonko
possibly probably not but it would be
nearly impossible for anyone to knock
him out but would this cowardly
character ever have what it takes to
become Joy boy and actually awaken his
devil fruits again there's a fair
argument for him probably not doing it
but we're also talking about a Really
Brave person here with Usopp and also
this video would be a whole lot
interesting obviously if he doesn't so
what would usub do with the powers of
the aw sun god naika well first off Uso
is straight up a super creative inventor
consistently making use of Technologies
like dials to make weapons like Kabuto
and the climb ATT attack and so on and
so forth and so having the ability to
bring anything in his imagination into
life would make this creative character
super overpowered like just imagine an
overpowered Godly Uso I mean they said
it couldn't be done but here it is and
uh yeah we're hoping that ALB will kind
of fix that too but really all of the
battle he's won so far he had to do so
with his Ingenuity to compensate for his
lack of physical power he's used
everything from hot sauce to plants to a
paper match version of his own face to
win battle so far but with the NAA fruit
awakened he could presumably just bring
these things into reality without much
limitation at all after all in the EAD
island arc we actually saw Luffy create
actual physical goggles with his gear
five powers and we're not sure what the
upper limit actually is but it does seem
like this fruit can just spontaneously
create objects and if that's the case
then Usopp is sure to make perfect use
of them on the other hand it's a little
bit less clear how Nami would make use
of Luffy's devil fruit in fact how would
she find it in the first place well to
be fair the time that arlong came to
take over nami's home Village was
actually around the same time that
Shanks actually brought the gumgum fruit
to the east blue so let's just say that
after she joined up with the arlong
Pirates to protect a village and began
sealing treasure she found herself in
Vint Mill Village and lifted the box
from the red pirate ship while they were
busy parting probably now the problem
for Nami is this box doesn't contain any
gold just this big purple piece of fruit
so she was especially hungry that day
and so voila we have robber Nami now how
would Nami use this fruit well in its
base form when she's just made out of
rubber it's really hard to say now one
really dark thought that comes to mind
is that it could actually be sort of a
disadvantage while she's still with
arlong I mean the fishermen Had No
Reservations about making Nami Safa so
they'll most certainly use the devil
fruit's weakness to water as a method of
torture but honestly that's a little bit
too dark to think about so instead let's
go to the fun stretchy stuff instead now
Nami could use her newly elastic body to
actually squeeze into some really tight
places in order to find treasure and
then steal that treasure and while Luffy
uses his body almost exclusively for
combat purposes Nami would figure out
how to turn her new powers into a
stealth tool as well for instance she
could access hard to reach places by
flinging herself into somewhere
squeezing into tight quarters and so on
and so forth and and if she ever was to
be captured it'd be no problem either
for her to just squeeze right out of the
bars of a jail cell and of course in
addition her Mastery of the weather in
combat would gain a huge Advantage I
mean she already loves to summon
lightning to electrocute her opponents
but with Luffy's rubber body Nami could
just conjure as much lightning as
possible without any risk of taking any
damage herself in other words her
Thunderbolt Tempo would be absolutely
insane I mean talk about a shocking
development and of course if Nami went
full gear 5 she wouldn't even need her
climate attack anymore because she could
just pull lightning and storm and
anything right out of the sky
willy-nilly and of course if Nami
actually managed to awaken this fruit it
would be well fruitful for her
navigation career as well you see the
grand line seas are absolutely
treacherous but by using gear 5's
ability to affect terrain and make other
objects bouncy she could just have the
thousand Sunny safely trampoline its way
through the new world with little regard
for the weather at all and also
depending on how exactly Na's
imaginative Powers work she might even
be able to just stop storms or reshape
the weather itself the only truly tragic
thing here though is that in gear five
Nami would lose the Luscious orange
locks that she's known for but that's
really the only downside for her here
and that already leads us to Chopper and
we saved the most interesting one of the
three for last actually now Chopper has
next to no reason to run into Shanks and
Co so we're going to say that in this
timeline lucky rug got really sick on
the way back to the east blue and the
redhead Pirates actually had to seek
medical attention on drum Islands you
know that big fat piece of meat that
he's always holding must have finally
gone bad and given him a really bad
stomach Buck also for some reason here
their doctor hongo just couldn't cut it
in time also it turns out that Shanks
has a doctor on his crew I mean who knew
however Dr Kura fixed luyu right up but
not for a stray reindeer took a bite of
gumgum and turned into the walking
talking reindeer that we all know and
love now as we know our favorite blue
noosed reindeer became a super
intelligent being when he ate the hito
honomi model nothing I guess like this
plain old human fruit gave him all the
powers of a person so we're just going
to imagine that the human human fruit
model NAA will still Grant him the
Baseline and then some more so long
story short he'll be the same old
Chopper we're used to just ier and
scratchier I guess now the catch here is
Chopper would of course awaken his devil
fruit way sooner than Luffy thanks to a
little thing he developed called a
rumble ball in case you forgot the
rumble ball is a pill that Chopper
developed that allows him to alter his
Zone fruit transformations to unlock
additional forms that aren't just
reindeer human or hybrids and so with
this he can utilize forms like brain
Point horn point and guard Point not to
be confused with a point guard to my
knowledge Chopper has never actually
once played basketball now of course
Sanji got his food Wars crossover so
maybe one day Chopper will make his way
into slam dunk hopefully not as the ball
anyways Chopper's Transformations get
insane though if he overdoses on the
rumble balls if he eats three Rumble
balls at once things get really crazy
and he transforms into the powerful
monster points this is a form that was
incredibly cool when we first saw it and
now for some reason has the downside of
making him talk like an old man okay now
based on Monster Point similarity to the
impul down Jaya beasts who are theorized
to be awakened devil fruit users gone
Rog this Rumble ball overdose appears to
be able to force a devil fruit to awaken
and another piece of evidence for this
transformation is that beo lost mink
crew mate was able to force himself into
a suong transformation as well using a
rumble ball now the Mink's suong
Transformations do involve also the mink
growing stronger and turning white with
red ice purely similar to how gear five
Luffy looks if you know what I mean now
the only thing is Chopper monster point
and the imple down jailers don't have
the little cloud ring that Luffy and
Luchi have in their awakened forms now
in case you don't know in Japan this is
meant to resemble this thing right here
which is called a hagoromo that many
deities are depicted wearing so there's
a possibility that instead of achieving
true Awakening like Luffy initially at
least Chopper's forced Awakening would
be kind of some sort of terrible bouncy
mindless Beast probably kind of
resembling a suong Ming that can yet
control the power of its transformation
but assuming that the three Rumble ball
trick does actually work Choppa would
probably have awakened the NAA fruit way
earlier before the rest of the crew even
arrived at drum islands and honestly
with that kind of power the reindeer
could have easily kicked wole out of the
country for sure turning drum Island's
Castle into Dr Korea's permanent
residence and with gear 5's
imagination-based Powers he could also
easily brought Dr Hero's dream to life
and made sakura trees blossom on the
island I mean forget making the mountain
look like a cherry blossom tree he
probably could have just gotten them to
straight up Bloom for real and again
we're not 100% sure what the limits of
this fruit are but could Chopper use it
to bring his other dream to fruition to
actually cure any disease I'd like to
think so because of how this fruit truly
works and if you want to have a complete
breakdown and explanation of how the NAA
fruit actually works and what its
abilities really can do you can check
out my video about that right here
Shanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one